august 1939 seemed to neville
chamberlain like a good month for taking
a long lazy holiday
he had plans to go fishing in scotland
on august the 2nd he won a vote in the
house of commons
to adjourn for two months everyone had
been working hard he reasoned and
deserved a break
said chamberlain parliament has dealt
with all that will be necessary at the
present
and we can be assured that the country
is ready for
any emergency winston churchill couldn't
believe his
ears this is an odd moment he said for
the house to declare
that it will go on a two-month holiday
did the prime minister
realize that hitler now had his eye on
poland
and that war could break out at any
minute warren churchill
all along the polish frontier from
danzig to krakow
there are heavy massings of troops
but chamberlain having learned almost
nothing from his mistakes at munich in
1938
insisted on an adjournment and got it he
was determined to go fishing
and was soon happily on his way to
scotland
bitterly churchill shook his head in
disbelief
and worried that britain might soon be
plunged into war
while her leaders were scattered from
london
for many months in the leadership vacuum
created by chamberlain
there had been an effort by churchill to
act in effect
as a prime minister in waiting he had
his own small circle of friends and
advisors
and his own independent sources of
foreign and military intelligence
and extensive contacts abroad especially
in france
though he and chamberlain were both
tories it was as if
they inhabited separate universes
chamberlain was clearly lost
in a thick fog of illusion clinging
stubbornly
to his idealistic theories and dreams
at some point reality would bring him
crashing to earth and churchill planned
to be there to pick up the pieces
for the nation's sake and his own now
more than ever he wanted to be prime
minister
every part of churchill seemed to ache
for the chance to lead a country that
had been adrift for too long
on the verge of turning 65 he wasn't
much younger than chamberlain
and didn't seem in any better shape
physically he ate too much
smoked too much and drank more than he
should
but there was a fire in his heart and a
thousand wheels turning in his brain
and suddenly with hitler untamed and on
the loose
churchill sounded and acted like someone
half his age
girding himself for the greatest fight
of his life
one that was a long time in the making
he had become
chamberlain's shadow a contrary figure
always there
to point in the opposite direction as
the prime minister tried to lead the
country
elsewhere his friends
told chamberlain that he might as well
bring churchill into the cabinet
and since the fall of czechoslovakia the
public seemed to want churchill in the
government as well
chamberlain however couldn't stand the
idea of churchill
upstaging him and contradicting him in
cabinet meetings
and knew that he wouldn't have a
moment's peace as a result
he also believed that giving churchill
an important position
would upset hitler and he was anxious
not to do that
churchill was impressed by the many
miles of defenses and admired
the intricate system of weapons pointing
at the german border
and liked the look of the french
soldiers positioned
along it he was much less impressed by
the
gaps in the maginot defenses near the
ardan
forest the french were quick to assure
him
that the germans could not hope to break
through its rugged terrain
he tried to make them reconsider their
view and to take greater precautions
in the area remember he said that we are
faced with a new weapon
armor and great strength on which the
germans are no doubt
concentrating and that forests will be
particularly tempting to such forces
since they will offer concealment from
the air
like chamberlain the french generals
were set in their views and thought
churchill was being unnecessarily
alarmist
they would regret not taking his advice
meanwhile reports farther east in poland
continued to indicate that hitler was
about to make his biggest move yet
like the czechs the polls in an
independent nation of their own
stood in hitler's path of conquest again
the dictator's problem was how to crush
a small country
while keeping the larger powers at bay
through intimidation
and negotiation or actual force
both britain and france had declared
that they would stand by poland
in the event that its independence was
threatened hitler
felt that he could deal with them in due
time but
what about his arch enemy the soviets
who set like a hulking goliath
on poland's eastern border
in a move straight from the
machiavellian playbook hitler persuaded
stalin
to join him in attacking poland and
dividing the spoils of polish territory
between them for sheer cynicism
wrote the american journalist william
shire the nazi dictator had met his
match
in the soviet despot stalin had not
figured much in chamberlain's dealings
with hitler
but the soviet leader made the cool
calculation
that if the british and french could
carve up territory to appease hitler
then he could do it too but take a piece
for himself in the process
as for hitler he thought he was baiting
a trap with a little portion of
something the other side wanted and then
at his convenience later on he would
snatch everything away for himself
this particular trap for aggression was
called
with orwellian doublespeak a
non-aggression pact
what it meant in practical terms is that
germany could grab
half of poland now and seize the rest
when it was convenient to betray
the soviets either because the western
powers failed to intervene
or were neutralized
europe hadn't seen anything like this
since napoleon
at that point characters like napoleon
had seemed the kind of leader you met
only in school books it was impossible
for most people to realize
that another little tyrant had appeared
almost out of nowhere
and was now acting like war was his only
policy
bullying and double dealing his way
across
europe step back for a minute
and consider the gravity of events at
this moment
you have a dictator in hitler who has
managed to gain
absolute control over a large mass of
land in central europe
with tens of millions of people under
him and in
august as chamberlain is fishing he is
preparing to move east and
slice up another country killing or
enslaving
millions more as churchill
understood hitler's plans were being
implemented
like stages in a race each turn made
with increasing speed
one day if you've wasted enough valuable
time
you wake up and the nazi flag is flying
over your capital
as the french would soon discover
because of their delays
and indecision in august 1939 the
british
were better prepared to fight than they
would have been
a year earlier but the raf was still
struggling to reach its necessary
strength the royal navy was facing new
threats from germany's
improved submarines and until very
recently the british army at home
had been a relatively small force of
only several divisions
this was the legacy not only a prime
minister chamberlain
but also of his predecessor stanley
baldwin
on the continent the british could do
little but reinforce the french
and few dare to imagine what might
happen if the french
with all of their resources in a country
the size of texas
were overrun by the germans
you can understand why churchill was
spending part of august
staring at the supposedly impregnable
maginot defenses
if they failed the british would have to
face germany alone
with only a narrow strip of water the
english channel separating them
from the most barbaric invasion force
since ancient times
in quieter days the universities and
various political adversaries
could mock churchill but now sensing
real danger
the whole country began turning to him
hoping that he had the answers to
questions that they had waited too long
to ask on august the 18th the times of
london
came out with an extraordinary call for
chamberlain to include churchill in the
government
amazingly it was endorsed by hundreds of
staff members
from every british university before the
prime minister could act
on this advice the nazis made their
aggressive
non-aggression pact with stalin and
swept into poland launching the
blitzkrieg
assault that would work so well on
unsuspecting
or ill-prepared defenders chamberlain
rested but perhaps not all that
refreshed by his
scottish holiday learned of the polish
invasion on september 1st
but true to his nature he waited until
september the third
to declare war hoping somehow
that hitler could be persuaded to recall
the troops
as if a blitzkrieg was only a rowdy
picnic
you could cancel at a moment's notice
chamberlain couldn't even make up his
mind about how to employ churchill
on september the 1st he asked him to
join the cabinet without giving him a
specific office
and waited in agonizing 24 hours before
telling churchill the big news
that he would be once again first lord
of the admiralty
it was a painful decision for
chamberlain forcing him to admit that
peace
had failed and that the country needed a
powerful hand
at the controls of what was still
britain's greatest
military force the royal navy winston is
back
the naval chiefs signaled to the fleet
or so the legend goes
this was the beginning of churchill's
vindication and everyone knew it
because he had been such an unrelenting
critic of appeasement
and of the slow pace of re-arming
britain
and because he had been told so often
that he was wrong
he could now let the unfolding events in
poland show
that he had been right all along yet no
one
not even churchill could put the case
for war in this particular time and
place
in a way that would be entirely logical
wars aren't logical and that's why there
is so much room for debating
whether this move or that move made
sense
consider for example the stunning
omission of the soviet union
from britain's plan for war was it
logical to fight germany over the
invasion of poland
and not fight russia which sent the red
army into poland on september the 17th
1939 by the end of the month stalin's
forces had overrun most of the polish
resistance
in the eastern part of the country and
had taken hundreds
of thousands of prisoners about 20 000
prisoners
mostly polish officers and a large group
of the educated elite
were killed in mass executions in the
following spring
the british excuse was that they had
promised to defend poland
against germany not russia the french
didn't have an excuse so the illogical
answer is that the soviets were given
a pass neither the french nor the
british wanted to fight
both hitler and stalin add to this the
fact that
many in the west believed that stalin's
alliance with germany was merely an
expedient ploy
it was seen as his way of buying time to
prepare
for war against his temporary partner
in crime churchill
was one of the few leaders in the west
who was
honest enough to say precisely why
hitler
not stalin was being held to account for
the attack on poland
his argument wasn't logical but simply
realistic
in his first radio speech of the war
churchill said
russia has pursued a cold policy
of self-interest clearly necessary for
the safety of russia
against the nazi menace i cannot
forecast to you
the action of russia it is a riddle
wrapped in a mystery
inside an enigma but perhaps there is a
key
that key is russian national interest
in hitler churchill saw a maniac
with whom not even friends could reason
he was a danger to everyone in the
soviets he saw a tyrannical state
that nevertheless kept its national
interests in mind
and might yield to pressures that
recognized the importance
of that self-interest he was already
looking for an
ally against hitler on an eastern front
that did not yet exist
just as he was already looking two years
before pearl harbor
for an ally in america to help him on
the western front
he could see far enough ahead to realize
that britain and france
could not carry the war deep into
central europe
and eradicate on their own the nazi
menace
as he called it without help from at
least one
other major power
interestingly his radio remarks about
russia
also included a fascinating connection
that he wanted to draw
between a landmark war against slavery
and the current fight against nazism
a connection in which he hoped america
would soon see the chance
for forging a common front against
hitler
this is what he said of all the wars
that men have fought
in their hard pilgrimage none was more
noble
than the great civil war in america
nearly 80 years ago
both sides fought with high conviction
and the war was long and hard
all the heroism of the south could not
redeem their cause
from the stain of slavery just as all
the courage and skill
which the germans always show in war
will not
free them from the reproach of nazism
with its intolerance and brutality
some americans in the old south weren't
pleased by this comparison and churchill
did worry
that he had gone too far but his target
audience
really an audience of one franklin
roosevelt reported that he was very
pleased
by the remarks even at this very
early stage of the war when he was only
a newly minted member of the war cabinet
churchill was using his knowledge of
history and strategy
to cast his net far and wide to draw in
the necessary allies
to make sure that hitler was crushed
before he had the chance to destroy
europe it wouldn't be pretty it wouldn't
always be logical
but it was a strategy that would work
and it began with churchill's practical
as opposed to theoretical understanding
of how wars
are won or lost
we can fault churchill for individual
episodes in the war when judgment failed
him
but not on the larger question of
victory where his eye was always firmly
fixed
so many wars start with no plan for
victory no firm purpose
or clear aim through all the fogs of war
that inevitably
rolled through the european theater of
conflict churchill's aim
was always to surround hitler and
destroy nazism
at its root that is his central and
enduring legacy
but mistakes were made especially in the
early months of the fighting
when britain was still scrambling to
pull itself
into a war footing and when the french
were still hunkered behind the maginot
line hoping
that the germans wouldn't be tempted to
test its
supposed invulnerability though
chamberlain announced
that britain was at war in september he
organized no major offensive against
germany
partly because he wanted to respect the
neutrality of belgium
and hold british troops back in france
to await the expected nazi invasion
only then would the allies move forward
to engage with the enemy
the problem was that the british forces
on the ground were never larger than 10
percent of the french army
in effect they were a token force not
especially well equipped or well trained
if the french didn't take the lead the
british were in no position
to move on their own
waiting for your enemy to make the first
big move is
never a good strategy and as the months
of the so-called
phony war dragged into 1940 the british
public grew
increasingly frustrated with
chamberlain's caution
what they did not know is that since
september
churchill had been urging the war
cabinet to undertake a risky assault on
the port of narvik in northern norway
where vital iron ore for the german
steel industry
was being shipped out along the coast in
the safety
of neutral waters it's debatable whether
stopping the shipping would deal germany
the severe blow that
church will imagine but he was
determined to make chamberlain
take some decisive action before as he
expected
the germans themselves occupied norway
to safeguard
their supplies of iron ore
again the question of the laws of
neutrality gave chamberlain pause
if the british were not willing to enter
belgium why should they go into norway
cabinet debates over this and other
questions entangled the prime minister
and a major assault was put off for so
long
that when it did come in april it was
far too late and too disorganized
the germans staged their own invasion of
norway at about the same time
and with better equipment and better air
cover they easily prevailed
leading to a disastrous defeat for the
british who were forced to retreat
it looked for a moment as though
churchill would have his return
to the admiralty abruptly ended by a
major tragedy
like the one in the dardanelles in 1915.
again
he had made a bold suggestion and
watched his plans undermined by delays
and confusion as in the case of the
dardanelles
he was trying to strike a surprise blow
outside of the central theater of war
his main fault was not so much in the
execution of the plan
where so many others had a hand in
making a mess of it but in pushing the
idea
in the first place chamberlain's
indecisiveness
caused churchill to take his eye off the
only thing that really mattered
in 1939-1940 stopping
hitler from overrunning france
not only did belgium neutral or not need
to be fortified against the expected
attack
but also that vulnerable spot at the
ardan forest
where the maginot defenses ran out and
needed
major reinforcement the french were so
sure of its insignificance that they
left it defended by some of their oldest
and least capable troops
of course this is exactly where one
german army
burst through in may 1940 while another
moved into belgium it was a brilliant
ploy french and british troops
raced north to save belgium and found
that the german forces coming through
the yard and
were sweeping through france right
behind them trapping them
and leaving only one little enclave for
escape
the channel port in france near the
belgian border
dunkirk by the spring of 1940
there were more than 300 000 british
troops in france
whose own army numbered in the millions
correctly deployed these forces should
have been able to fight the germans
for a lot longer than six weeks but
that's all the time it took
for the enemy to win in a route perhaps
more than any other british leader
churchill wanted to keep the troops
fighting alongside the french when
hitler invaded
but years of neglect had given britain a
land force ill-equipped
to stop the germans and the panic among
french leaders
soon made it clear that they lacked the
will to save their
own country
norway was a sideshow yet it is also
true that the british
expeditionary force in france could not
alone have stopped germany
at the ardan or elsewhere without more
men
and better arms especially tanks and
anti-tank weapons
the truth is that as first lord of the
admiralty churchill could do little to
reverse
the perilous position of the outnumbered
and outgunned british forces
and its complacent french partner wedded
to a bad strategy of defensive war
and plagued from the start by frankly a
defeatist
attitude the british public
understood in 1940 that churchill had
been in the cabinet
for only a few months and that his
leader chamberlain
had played a prominent part in
government for years
and that this same prime minister was
now painfully exposed as a national
failure
whose sheet of paper heralding an age of
peace
had turned out to be an empty promise
it wasn't luck or subterfuge that saved
churchill from another dardanelle
disaster
in the case of norway in 1915 he had
been the target of a lot of
unhappy politicians who yearned for his
downfall
in 1940 it was chamberlain who found
himself
in this position
however much he misjudged the situation
in norway
churchill was at least trying to find a
way to engage the germans in war
and to win despite his failings the
norway campaign
resulted in the sinking of several
german ships causing serious damage to
hitler's
navy and hampering its ability to launch
an invasion
of the english coast later that year
after
so many fruitless years of talk about
peace agreements
and arms reductions the sheer brutality
of the nazi war machine made the british
people
want to see a bit of fighting spirit in
their leaders
churchill had that chamberlain did not
and the public turned on him holding him
as head of the government to be the one
most responsible
for the government's failures on may 8
1940 just two days before the germans
invaded holland and belgium
churchill's old rival from the first
days of the
first world war the former prime
minister david lord george
now a white-haired political veteran of
77
stood up in the house of commons and
made an extraordinary speech
confessing to the whole house that he
felt he had been misled
by stanley baldwin in the big questions
of war and peace that churchill had been
right
on those matters all along and that
chamberlain had
failed to lead the country now that it
was at war
the speech was a political death blow
for the prime minister
here is what lord george said for three
or four years i thought to myself that
the facts with regard to germany
were exaggerated by the first lord
meaning churchill
because the then prime minister in other
words baldwin
said that they were not true the first
lord was right about it then
came the war the tempo was hardly
speeded up
there was the same leisureliness and
inefficiency
nobody is satisfied the whole world
knows that
and here we are in the worst strategic
position in which this country
has ever been placed chamberlain not
only had to suffer through this
humiliating speech but also to exit the
house that day
with members shouting at his back go go
go go the atmosphere was so full of
hostility
toward chamberlain that one of his
remaining allies on the floor thought
that the prime minister
might be physically attacked what
winchen churchill
went through in 1915 when he was the
scapegoat
for war going badly was nothing compared
to this
very public rejection of a prime
minister
whose armies were about to come under
attack in france
churchill graciously attempted in the
debates to take some of the blame on
himself
but lord george said to the house that
the first lord of the admiralty
didn't need to take the flack intended
for others as he put it
offensively churchill must not allow
himself to be converted into an air raid
shelter
to keep the splinters from hitting his
colleagues
chamberlain should have realized at this
point that he was finished
his resignation would be the price
exacted not only for the actions in
norway
but also for the inaction everywhere
else
vainly however he tried to hang on
pleading with the labor party to support
him
in a new government of national unity it
was only when
they refused that he accepted his fate
his half-spoken wish was that churchill
would not succeed him yet he was
thwarted in that
as well calling both churchill and lord
halifax to a meeting
he asked halifax whether he would be
willing to lead a new government
halifax not only declined the offer but
also added
winston would be a better choice that
sealed the matter
chamberlain resigned and on the evening
of may the 10th 1940
king george vi took chamberlain's advice
and asked winston churchill to form a
new government
the chamberlain dynasty going all the
way back to joe chamberlain birmingham
was finished and churchill who had
gotten the better of joe
four decades earlier now replaced
neville as prime minister
he was 65. europe was in flames
and he was about to lead britain in the
greatest fight
of its life even as the misadventure in
norway was still being played out
churchill within only a month of taking
office
would find himself facing one of the
most serious challenges
any prime minister had ever seen so
rapidly
with the french fall before the german
advance that over a quarter of a million
men
mostly british would find themselves
trapped between the sea
and the nazis on the beaches of dunkirk
faced was such a disaster coming so
close on the heels of the retreat from
norway
a different kind of prime minister might
have sued for peace
but the old war horse who had taken the
job had the advantage of experience that
went back to his days as a prisoner
in the boer war an officer in the
trenches of the first world war
and more recently a political cassandra
whose
unheated warnings were now being played
out so
dangerously close to london itself
how did winston churchill change the
world
join me for our next lecture and we will
try to count the ways
at the end of the road that led to
[Music]
dunkirk
[Music]
you